Ahoj.
OK.
Ahoj.
Ahoj ahoj.
Ta.
Ahoj, dobré odpoledne.
Řekl bych něco.
Ahoj.
Něco.
Ahoj.
Správná odpověď je něco.
Tak.
A tohle je super,
kdyžtak mi případně máme zasedačku
station dole, tak rádi vás uvidíme.
Tak.
Prosím tě radši bychom teda týdenní
radihu radši bychom párkrát PI jo jo ty,
které si řekneš nebudou všechny.
Já jsou jenom nějaké vybrané.
A potom bychom přeskočili na pravidelný,
který místa to z projektů s tím,
že já mám tam pár otázek k těm datum,
AK těm nabídkám, tak mi asi řeknete sami,
jak se to vyvíjí ty nabídky ten den zase
máme, máme středu, není,
který není pondělí tak,
jak se to vyvíjí ty nabídky myšleno
elektro a data.
Máme tam teda firmu cepena.
Tak jak to tam vypadá?
A to já se vždycky doptám a potom bychom
vždycky jenom klikli na ty milníky,
který jsem si s každým z vás prošel a
nějak jsme je centralizovali.
Zjednodušili jsme, aby byli na 1.
Místě a aby nebyli nějaký 2 místa,
odkud by navíc,
aby si ty milníky souhlasili.
Já se potom totiž čerpám proto, že tak.
Někdo takhle může být ona i slovo ještě
nepotřebuji.
Já teďka jdu sdílet jenom já se omlouvám.
Na to nemusím říkat, že to jenom.
Ta KPI.
Kaplíčka a.
Tady jo už to bude tak 1 to abychom vzali
pár těch KPI si prosím tě na co
potřebuješ.
A pak by tam rozpočet na projekty.
Tam tedy.
Tak.
Tady nemáme.
Ano to, co všechno viděl na, řekla 6.
Jenom v krátkosti.
Týden 22. Drážťané brutální pokles,
brutální pokles, produktivity.
37.
Zjišťoval jsem důvody aktuálně ty důvody,
které jsem dostal,
tak je vysokej příjem nízká expedice,
což nám zamíchalo samozřejmě s
produktivitou.
Protože příjem není tak produktivní ve
chvíli vysokej objem, tak se tolik toho,
tak se tak jobline,
jestli do toho propíšu málo,
ale hodně hodně hodin Ondra říkal,
že stahovali, že stahovali nějakej bacot.
To znamená tady ten propad,
kterej tam v produktivitě chrášťan je,
tak je primárně způsobenej,
tak je primárně způsobenej.
Touhle tou změnou jinak. Když se podíváme,
tak je tam hezky vidět.
Také strašně hezky vidět to,
jak se na tenkrát, tak je hezky vidět,
jak se opakujou.
V takový ambitě podle propadyrůsty
samozřejmě to souvisí s tím, že ve chvíli,
kdy máme dostatečnej objem, to znamená.
To znamená výplatní termíny,
tak ta produktivita jde nahoru.
Aktualizujeme lidi.
Ve chvíli to klesne tak to neumíme
zdualizovat,
takže to je nějaký úkol na kluky z
provozu,
že tohle to je potřeba jako výrazně líp
řídit výrazně líp řídit jinak střílet 44
produktivity.
Tady máme tady 43 Ondra počítá s cílem 44
jsme vzdálený ještě jako řádově 5
procentních bodů těch silných týdnech.
Potřebujem se tam zvednout všude.
Tady možná je takovej jako bod na na na.
Pokud bylo by dobrý,
kdybyste se všichni ale ušetřil v
procesákama,
ale kdybyste se všichni zamysleli nad tím,
jestli vidíte někde potenciál,
jak tu produktivitu zvýšit,
kde pálíme zbytečný hodiny,
který který v tuhle chvíli,
který v tuhle chvíli můžeme nahradit
něčím jako automatizovaným?
Jenom z velké části ta z velké části ty
hodiny ležej a jídlo hodinách,
což jsou jako neaktivitový hodiny.
To znamená buď toto jsou prostory pickerů,
balíčů a tak dále.
Nebo nějaký jako přebíhání po skladu?
Třeba koukáš nebo a nebo a nebo si na něj
pracoviště nebo jako s autostoru na
manuální zónu.
Tak je tam nějakej další časovej úsek.
Teď to pane doajdu.
Tak to jako může bejt 1 1 bod a nebo
další padaj do toho veškerý neaktivitový
činnosti jako administrátoři vedoucí
posunovači, palet, tyčkaři a tak dále.
To znamená,
musíme se primárně zaměřovat tady na ty
části toho procesu,
protože tam leží nejvíc největší
potenciál toho,
kde ty úspory líznou a kde to nějakým
způsobem jako chytře nahradit.
Není to o tom,
že že máme jako začít šetřit,
protože to bude mít dopad do do kvality,
ale máme začít dělat ty věci jako
chytřeji a ten kde to jde,
jenom zautomatizovat,
tak to prostě zautomatizovat.
Máme nějaký jako činnosti u ver minu,
který jdou jako jednoduše,
jednoduše bouchat nějakou urychlou
automatizaci, tak je to jako 1 věc,
kterou máme,
kterou máme následovat pro ty devinuty
taky už nebo nemálo,
tak to je jenom takový.
Podnik,
že k té produktivitě 43 jsme jako
vzdálený poměrně.
Poměrně ještě jako daleko.
Ten průměr jsme někde u 40.
Měli bysme si na průměr dostat 43 44,
takže 10 procentních bodů ještě mám 10
10%. Ještě jako nám chybí k tomu,
aby jsme byli na tom průměru, kde má bejt.
Je to jenom taková.
Takovej úvod a je to vlastně zpráva AV
rámci projektu, nebo i mimo když jde,
o vidím něco tak, aby nebyla ta zpráva,
protože většina těch projektů,
který tady děláme, je zaměřena na.
Výkon, případně kapacitu,
to znamená v tuhle chvíli v tuhle chvíli
je to primární něco jako nad rámec.
Pokud pokud budete mít nějakou blbě a
kdybyste se každý zamyslel nad tím,
jestli jako existujou nějaký části,
který je možný, je možný. Vlastně se jako.
Kde můžeme pro tu produktivitu navýšit,
kde můžeme tu produktivitu navýšit.
Tak to je to je 1 bod druhej bod minulej
tejden kvalita 87 způsobeno expedice
dohoena doprava způsobeno primárně tím,
že byly jako velký změny v rámci
nastavení doprav.
A tam byly nějaké doběhy doběhy těch
starých svozů. Je to něco,
co si vzal nebo co si za vlastně Michal
Gottwald i Michaela, abychom měli,
protože tohle tohle je vlastně jako
change management. Měníme typy svozů,
je to nějaký nějaká změna uvnitř toho
procesu provozu?
Zaživa vlastně my nezastavíme provoz,
ale děláme tu změnu za běhu,
tak tohle to potřebujeme takhle výrazně i
podchycené a potřebujeme.
Dostatečně dopředu.
Komunikovat je s nějaký jako vědět,
kolik na to,
jaká část potřebuje času a mít 1
odpovědnou osobu,
která na tu změnu vždycky doobídne.
To je tady,
to je tady si to vzal Michal a bude,
budeme to měnit směrem vod vod plánovačů
od plenů.
Tak to se jim jako 2 komentáře teďka tady
k těm jako číslům,
který tam za poslední 2 týdny svítěj
bohužel ne úplně jako podč.
Takže mám otázku,
celé 24 by to bylo jako s *****,
nebo jsme tam mohli letět,
nebo na mě třeba více týmová záležitost
samozřejmě záleží na těch změnách.
Příští týden se musí odehrát 0 změna a
bude všechno dobrý. Jo, tam jde o to,
že když tu změnu uděláme,
tak ať tam není ten propad.
No a my se to pak můžeme jako vyhodnotit,
já nevím,
budem prostě dělat nové trasy pro prahu a
střední Čechy,
tak tam si jako můžeme říct. OK,
tak tady jako nesmíme jít pod 93 a
poznáme, jestli jsme to udělali správně,
nebo ne.
Ale příští týden to jako nepozná,
že příští týden tam prostě bude.
3 4 dny další v budoucnu nekoukali na
smutné čísla. To byla ta otázka.
Ano,
mělo by se to srovnat já akorát nevím jak
dlouho ten propad bude trvat,
jestli bude trvat jako 1 tejden nebo
jestli bude trvat 2 týdny.
A budu správně jakoby mimo banány,
dopravy a banánů, obě 2 strany rovnice,
ale je to jako 1 změna.
Která může mít dopad na obě části in a au
baran a samozřejmě jako ve chvíli,
kdy máme nekvalitu na expedici,
tak se to nějakým způsobem jako promítá
do kvality doručení.
Protože ne kvalita neexpedici nemusí
znamenat, že jsme to neodeslali,
ale většinou to odešlem pozdě.
Tím pádem auto odjíždí pozdě a tak dále.
Proč je to?
Jo tam, já ještě se přidám k tobě ing,
protože teďkon jak máme ty objemy opět
větší,
že jdeme prostě 200 KA jakoby než tak
prostě.
Třeba se ukázalo nějaký problémy na
depech,
to znamená u nás odeslání dobrých ty
posilovy auta. Bohužel při jízdě později,
protože musí čekat, než ty auta to naloží,
pak to dojede na ty depa,
ale tyhlencty oběmy už jsou třeba v tuhle
chvíli aktuálně nad kapacitou jako těch
dep, takže tam potom.
Se to jakoby zasekne a má to dopad na tu
kvalitu doručení.
Řešíme to tenhlecten tejden.
Vydepadl.
Dobře.
Jdeme dál prosím pro vás zpráva.
Vezměte si vezměte si tak nějak to za
svůj úkol. To že se zamyslíte,
nebo že se zkusíte zamyslet do příštího
týdne nad tím?
Který aktivity,
který vlastně jako nejsou v tuhle chvíli
úplně přímo aktivitový,
to znamená k té činnosti,
které nejsou úplně přímo aktivitové,
je možné zautomatizovat,
případně nějakým způsobem jako zlepšit
takovým způsobem, abychom,
abychom byli schopni u těch i tlů udělat
nějakou úsporu.
Zkusíme to vyhodnotit a zjistíme, kde,
kde, kde kde jsou vlastně ty prostory?
Jo prosím pro všechny.
Pro všechny informace.
Úkol.
Jdeme dál.
Já já mám kdyžtak 1 1 věc jsou já jestli
tady můžu ahoj.
Ano povídej.
K tomu k tomu 1 bodu.
Hnedka mám 1 věc 1 příklad,
kde se nám povedlo,
ale nepovedlo b jedná se o robotic,
kdy vlastně teď na příjmu jsme šli jak
efektivitou dolů,
tak hlavně i efektivitou zasklenění a je
to teďkon začínáme jako velkej problém,
protože řekneme například to jako iPhone
skvělej příklad, jo,
normálně se dávají na vejšku.
2 3 telefony do osminky a jede to.
Teď by se to dalo,
tak to musí být na plocho a nacpe se to
do čtvrtbinek nebo celobinek a tím pádem.
Ta efektivita je nižší a už je to ve
stavu, kdy teďkon provozuju.
Na autostoru dochází, no spíš došly.
Dneska došly čtvrtkový biny.
Tak to je třeba jako 1.
Z těch z těch příkladů si myslím,
že jsme se na to mohli podívat, jo,
protože my jsme si tady jako pomohli
Jo.
efektivitou na piku,
ale vlastně teďkon efektivita,
jak i to naskladňování pro to pro to tam
vlastně teďko máme i nějaký propad a to
bude vidět na těch číslech,
tak hlavně i jako efektivita toho
zasklenění šla jako hodně hodně do kytek.
Jo martine tohle je potřeba,
tohle je potřeba vzít v rámci toho
nastavování procesu pro to naskladnění.
To pro ten robot jo.
Hele ovšem o všem víme,
pravidelně to sledujeme.
Asi.
Já teda nesouhlasím,
že to je jenom robopik, ale to je asi 1.
Já se když tak projdu ještě s provozem AS
vítkem,
kdyžtak uděláme nějaký akční kroky.
Dobře jdeme dál. Počítám s tím,
že u lžice v tuhle chvíli přeskakuju,
protože tam nějakým způsobem jako pomalu
koreluje k finále k finále a jdeme rovnou
na to, kde by to mohlo bejt zajímavý,
což jsou de pálítku.
Ano.
Tak.
Bb i deba.
Se to tam mění, jak se to tam vyvíjí?
Jasně, tak teď nemáme teda změnu.
Co se týče počtu rozjetých systémů,
je spuštěnejch web,
protože tam jsme byli zase nějakým
Jo.
způsobem okolnostma typu infrastruktura.
Co se týče ty storky v it,
já jsem zmiňuju už jenom na dvojku,
protože tam jsou ty 2,
který nás teďka aktuálně trápí nejvíc.
Zase se budu opakovat,
ale zmíním ta 1 je co se týče toho
párování.
Balíku na bednu.
Ta 2 co se týče úpravy a čtečky do čtečky,
aby se mohly svozák zavírat čtečkou na
depech.
Co se týče tady teď kolonky,
co je označená,
to je podíl stor jobline tříděných
systémově.
Já jsem se v tom trošku víc hrabal.
Zjistil jsem,
že tam máme nějakou nějakou díru v balíku
jobech,
protože se mi povedlo vyfiltrovat ty kusy,
které byly skutečně roztříděný systémově,
ale.
V balíku, že bych to tak propsaný není,
ale co je směrodatný jsou,
je ten podíl storch vložený přes nonaté
svozový list.
To můžeme označit jako balík,
který prošel kompletně správně.
Tím procesem na depu to znamená musel být
přijatej roztřízenej a ná silně vloženej
na svazovej list je to jsou to teda data
zatím z 1 depa to znamená z hosinu,
a když se to vlastně porovná mezi těma
tejdnama, tak z těch 80% můžeme vidět.
Že tam jako to zlepšení je až v nějakejch
jako 10%.
Což teda patří jakoby velkej dík provozům,
chráštům a třídírny, protože je vidět,
že se to skutečně přestalo vkládat ručně
nebo velice omezilo.
A teďkon se vlastně hodí ještě pa letovi
štítky? Jo,
občas máme ještě zde 2 ňáký info,
že není polepeno, ale řešíme,
komunikujeme.
Takže.
Co chybí pro to, abychom co chybí pro to,
abychom měli jako počet uloženejch
systémově na svobodě,
kde 100% proč tam nemůže být 100%?
Já určitě teď zmíním tu zase tu storku,
co jsem říkal, jo, prostě jsou případy,
kdy to bude ručně vložený. Jo,
je to říkám nějaký ty advinský dořešování?
10% všech 10.
10% všech joe line v chráštěnech není
vložených systémové vyložených ručně.
Hm.
Ne, to jsem to jsem neřekl,
to ne je to je to vícero faktorů, jo,
jsou tam,
jsou tam třeba ty shozený štítky nebo v
okamžiku, kdy na paletě není štítek,
není jak to přijmout potom na depu.
Jo je to je to jako mix vícero věcí.
No samozřejmě.
Schozeny štítky na paletách jo.
Enhnm.
Jo,
ale jenom ještě a promiň 1 1 info co jsme
teď dostali v hosíně?
Stěžujou si na to a teď já nevím,
jak k tomu předcházel,
ale stěžujou si na to,
že když se spohujou palety na sebe,
které jsou na různý trasy,
tak jak je jako rozbalujou,
tak se jim ty štítky jako údajně můžou
trhat, pak jsou jako nepoužitelný,
takže tohle možná taky 1 věc, která.
Je tam jako brzdí v tom to procento mít
vyšší,
ale tam je zase spíš asi o šikovnosti než
o tom, že?
To se dává se to na tu strečku a ve
chvíli,
kdy se to nějak jako poškodí protrhávat,
tak je to jiná čísla.
Jo potřebujem jako vymyslet způsob,
kterým se dostanu na 100%,
protože a nebo prostě,
když to nejde přijmout,
tak ve chvíli to začnu třídit,
tak máme jako.
Tak máme ten balík aktivovat na tý
pobočce.
Nemůžeme tady mít 10% tak na krátkém čase
nemůžeme, nemůžeme mít 10% balík,
který jim nejdou třídit.
To by tam jako v životě nevyřešili.
Kvalita expedice se potom odráží.
Kvalita expedice se potom odráží od toho
To souhlasím.
kolik toho systému vložíme na slzák a
nebo je to způsobený něčím jiným.
Ji koresponduje to s tím s tím uložením
na svou záknu.
1 je za tých balíčků jobu 2 je za TZ
power BICA, co má i na sledování dopravy.
Se ukazoval David blahovec.
To se musíme ještě víc ku podívat, jo?
OK.
Dobře pojďme dál, Plzeň.
Jo tak na Plzni už jsou doplněný trasy.
To mi teďkončí v 15 plánovanejch s tím,
že.
Náklady na zásilku tu bych taky rád s
sebou s tebou si otočil,
abych uměl doplnit, abych věděl,
jak kvalitu třídění doplním.
To já se musím podívat do do toho do nový,
že nový q,
takže si musím sehnat sehnat data.
V provozu.
Co je ale důležitá informace?
Je kvalita expedice z depa.
Vidíme, že se držíme nějakých 95,6%.
Je to stejný stejný parametr nebo vzal
jsem to ze stejného místa,
jako je kvalita expedice z osina.
Tak vypadá, že to je dobrý.
Teda jestli to musíte říkal,
že tam potom na týden ta se to nasekává
nějaké tohle tu hornou kvalitu? Jo,
jo zajímavý teda.
Jo tady se tady se bavíme IO čase jo,
když auto vyrazí,
i kdyby o 5 minut později než než má,
tak už samozřejmě nám to padá do
dekvality expedice jo, takže tam.
Ale ta doručení za DMK je to doručení za
tím depem Plzeň, ale víš?
Ne to nevím znovu, ale můžu se podívat,
aby mi chvilku řeknu.
Zatím dál.
Příjem.
Tak.
Příjem tady je hodně ten propad na tom
optostoru, jak říkal, ale Martin,
nebude to způsobený jenom robotikem.
Já se koukal,
že vlastně vlastně tam máme dost podobnej
objem, třeba jakoby byl 2 3 týdny do sadu,
ale je tam vlastně na to použito jakoby
víc hodin,
co jsem si tahal tahal z powerbika?
Takže takhle.
Nevíme proč.
Zatím ne?
Říkám je 1. Z těch důvodů bude,
bude ten robot,
že je prostě potřeba být důkladně IS tím
manipulovat to jako zpomaluje ty lidi ale
evidentně těch faktorů tam bude víc.
Dobrý den.
Jít okomentovat tady ten propad.
Jak říkám, výkon napřímo je stejnej.
Produktivita je 30% horší.
Příjmová.
Tak to nedokážu teďkon.
Pár stejný informace,
nebo se koukáme na blbý čísla jenom
jestli jestli každý netaháme jiný čísla.
Já jako nevím, protože já,
když koukám na stor joblajny a na počet
jako byl zpracovanejch palet,
tak mi právě připadá,
že jedeme jako valíme docela dobře na to,
že prostě máme teďkon bookingy.
Ale.
Prostě já nevím 950 palet a držíme se
celkem slušně,
A.
tak jako mi to nějak jako nepřijde.
Hele já souhlasím s tady.
Já byl opatrnej s těma korelacema co s
čím souvisí,
protože ono jako například od začátku
dubna.
Do půlky května,
ještě než jsme začli vůbec s tou
deprementací nám taky jako klesla
efektivita o procento a půl v rámci
autostoru i bez toho robotiku, jo.
Takže jako čísla. Oni jsem měli stejný,
jen si musíme vyjasnit,
kde je ta korelace a co s tím souvisí
podle mě primárně.
Určitě.
Dobře.
Obecně spíš ode mě za tím stojí větší
objem v rámci autostoru a větší počet SK
úček, kde si myslím,
že bude větší větší závislost.
Ale říkám,
musíme na to kouknout z detailu,
to je jako odhad.
Já vám teďka,
když koukám do lock performance na
celkový na celkovou produktivitu příjmu.
Mi přijde za poslední nebo jako od
začátku května, že se zásadně nemění.
Je pravda, že v dubnu byla výrazně lepší.
Po výrazně ne byla po kousíček lepší.
Tohleto si potřebujem srovnat,
tomu rozumíme.
Protože teď vlastně nevím,
jestli je problém, nebo není.
Ty.
No já jediný,
co co se týkalo třeba potvrzování,
tak dneska už jsem jako klukům říkal,
že má zvednutej prst je středa a měli
jsme tam jako víc nepotvrzeno.
Jo ale zase furt zpracováváme stejný
počet palet prostě necháváme si tam
vždycky. Ano,
nějaký bufr na víkend abysme měli práci
pro lidi.
Ale jinak jako nemyslím si,
jako že jsme nějak výrazně spadli,
ale bohužel teda ani nezlepšili. Jo,
protože ono to je vždycky na základě
objednávky SPO, kde minulý tejden,
tak jsme měli nějakejch asi 750 k 800.
Teď jsme prostě přes 900.
Jo,
ale oni nám třeba jako teďka jako došli
víc a ve čtvrtinky jo,
že těch faktorů tam jako fakt hodně.
Jo jo jo.
No to je, aby prostě měl opatrný.
Já jsem na to šel s klukama sednu v pátek
jako na LC.
Vítku prosím mrkni na to jestli.
Koukni se na to s Martinem AS Davidem,
jestli ty hodnoty, který tam teďka svítí,
jestli jsou správně z jakejch dat to
bereme a je to z jakej z jakej dat.
To bereme,
jestli se koukáme na kvalitní čísla,
Jas.
prosím.
Jo, podíváme se společně.
Další věc.
Zaměřte dlouhodobě na na ty řádky,
který tady nemáme vyplněný jo,
ať tady máme vždycky na začátku furt tý
středy je plněný ty ty poličky,
který jsme si řekli,
že bych to nesledoval.
Ano.
Týden 89%.
Tohle minule je to den doručení 89.
Kvalita občanů.
Tohle je paráda.
Kde?
Martine teďka bych skočil prosím k tobě
roboting.
Co se týče robotiků?
Zase vrtčíme dále,
protože jsem vám se pokry těch 10000.
Co se týče kvalit a tak dále,
očekával tam větší skoky IV.
Průběhu následujících týdnů zaprvý by se
měla už víc projevovat ta dekantace a
hlavně za 2.
Máme domluvený se s ractem 3 velký updaty,
který by měly řešit věci jako double
picky,
ghospiky a především chybu itemsticky nám
to vibin.
Takže tyhle 2 věci by se spojily,
tak věřím, že kvalita nám bude dále růst.
Co dál vyšší čísla?
Co se týče statusu.
Jan.
Zatím se zde kvality týče,
tak se zasekla za poslední měsíc na 83
procentech, a to jako stagnuje spíš.
Víme o tom říkám,
potřebujem dost často tomu decorntingu a
potřebujem nasadit ty věci,
který tam máme.
V rámci toho toho robotku s sro
připravený.
Takže příští tejden se to zlepší, jo?
Martine.
Co.
Díky, to bude lepší.
Nevím,
jestli to bude příští tejden ty věci od
práci následujících týdnů jednotek týdnů,
což znamená někdy během června až začátku
července. Co se týče dekantingu,
tam výsledky jako očekáváme,
až budou postupně postupně růst v rámci
června, července a srpna.
To znamená,
že na lepší čísle se velmi pravděpodobně
začneme koukat.
Pro 4 týdny.
Je to odhad ano.
Martine.
Ty,
když tam dáváš teďka jako primárně ty
procenta kvality robotiků,
bereš to jenom jako timestem za poslední
jako n mínus 7 dní,
nebo to jako průměruješ ty výsledky celý
za to období.
Hele beru to za posledních 7 dnů.
OKOK dob.
OK.
Díky.
V tuhle chvíli bych šel na.
Různé, tak pojďme na projekty.
Martin šovinec máme to slovo jako 1.
Zkusím.
Tak.
V kli nejlepší hovořit.
Já tady budu proklikávat,
takže asi systémově de facto 1.
OK systémové depa v podstatě nový by jo
mohli jsme se infrastrukturou,
máme schváleno od míry nabídku od sepeny,
takže bysme se tam měli počítat v příštím
týdnu by to mělo být hotové a připravené.
V radimou máme připravené testovacích,
máme vybraných.
Máme datum,
kdy bychom tam chtěli dodělat live testy.
AA.
Na základě toho se rozhodnem gem co mám
poslat na info,
tak se připravuju podklady na finančně
vyhodnočeně a uvažuje se o 2 variantách.
Buď budova alzy nebo budova dopravce.
Co se týká strategie Slovenska,
tak tam se rozjelo dipomokrance.
Máme variantu přibližně 16 až 18 tras.
V této chvíli myškol se v jednaní z
lidlom.
A od 9 6 jsou v ies direct trasy,
které jsme navrhovali s Filipem,
takže ty už jsou všichni.
Dneska jsme s vítkem měli update s
Jakubem lukáčem,
který to má na starosti za systémové depa
na Slovensku.
Tak jsme si říkali nějaké postupné kroky,
které se musí udělat,
ať k tomu depu abysme tam mohli udělat
nějaké testy. A tak?
Co se týká next step,
tak nový by byl stanovi nafázovat.
Spustěni.
Tam musíme počkat ještě na tu minimálně
na tu 1 storku,
která k tomu zmiňoval Vítek a vraťme ho
zorganizovat. Life test depomogrance,
pokračovat na tom, co máme rozjeté,
tam máme sings do slova kmy.
Do teďka sedí na.
Do teďka sedí na tom.
Antonín hosíně,
abychom tam navyšovali ty kvality,
abychom zjišťovali ty příčiny a.
Nebo aktivně to aktivně to posouvali.
Jak to myslíš kdo tam sedí?
Tam nikdo není fyzicky existuje pouze
whatsappová skupina, kam se to reportuje.
Jedná se o to,
kdo teďka aktivně pracuje na tom,
abychom aby ty.
Ten podíl těch tříděných ta kvalita
expedice rychlost nakládky Michal říkal,
že tam je nějakej na hosíně problém s tím,
jak je tam mají layout a bude zaručený
následná, aby se to dostalo do čísel,
který který jako očekával za.
Tak, ale tohle je na straně,
ale dopravné na naší straně.
To se ptám, kdo to,
kdo to teďka aktivně řídí?
Ekologistickej.
Podle mě by to měli řídit ty,
který jsou zodpovědný za depa,
takže péťa Čechách za svým týmem? Já vím,
že tam aktivně chodí Ondra chudoba a
řešej to jestli jako je tam potřeba zásah
z logistiky a nebo náš tak za ty
informace musíme dostat ke mně nebo někam
jinam, ale já ty informace jako nemám,
takže jako ani o whatsappový skupině
nejsem, takže to je těžký.
Vyplene na vás 100 aktivně řídí,
kdo aktivně řídí.
Bude jako silné slovo, ale je pravda,
že Ondra tam jako pravidelně jezdí.
Nicméně my jsme se tam na tom byli včera
podívat s Markétou a je pravda,
že to třízení tak,
jak se tam odehrává dneska,
tak není úplně efektivní.
A ten největší problém za sebe vidím v
tom,
že každý řidič má trošku jako jiný postup
v rámci toho, jak to dělá.
Což do budoucna podle mě není udržitelné,
protože dne budeme schopni vyhodnotit,
kdo je dobrej,
kdo je špatnej každej to vlastně dělá
jinak to znamená,
my jsme si s panem hanzalíkem domluvili,
že se.
V blízké době sejdeme s ním AS tam s jeho
dispečera a nadepu v Plzni,
abychom jim ukázali,
jak si to představujeme a zároveň si
teďka jako s Ondrou chudobou podíváme na
ten layout toho holsinského depa.
Tam je problém,
že je relativně úzký a on má na šířku
nějaký 18m.
Ale zkusíme tam něco vymyslet tak,
aby těch jako 15 tras třídili stejným
způsobem, jako se třídí v Plzni,
protože tam se to osvědčilo.
Prago jedná se mi o to,
že v tuhle chvíli my máme mít nějaké jako
profuk concept toho,
že to jakým způsobem v tuhle chvíli
funguje na těch systémových debet
externích.
Ke správným a že nám to funguje,
ale my se tady.
3 tejdny blázáme na tom,
že 10 až 20% neumíme vůbec,
nebo vůbec nevložíme systémové na svozách.
Doručení jsem teďka nekoukal,
jaká je na husí,
nijak je zhruba je na Plzni je jako 90%,
tak potřebujeme,
aby tam jako někdo byl na místě a teď já
nevím, jestli to má bejt Ondra,
nebo jestli to má bejt někdo od nás,
nebo jestli to maj bejt,
školitelé nebo jak to má bejt někdo z
provozu, kdo prostě?
Tyhlety tyhlety věci budou odstraňovat a
bude postupně jako dostávat ty kvality
nahoru.
Jinak vydává smysl jako pouštět další
demo,
který bude úplně úplně stejnej troskách,
zvlášť jako v troskách.
U nás to trochu jako přehnal,
ale zvlášť jako pokud říkáme,
že hostin je nejšikovnější.
To.
S tím souvisí i to i to vlastně třízení
těch vratek,
protože to tam dneska jako není to
systémové třídění vratek a tam vůbec jako
já nevím, v jakém to je stavu,
jestli jestli tohle už je,
na čem se pracuje,
aby když ten řidič jako přiveze vratky
tak, aby je rovnou jako napípnul a víme,
že to máme zpátky na webu souvislosti s.
Těma s těma jako škodama ztrátama,
tak tam tam jako já nevím,
no tohle nesouvisí s kvalitou expedice s
podílem roztříděných systémově
roztříděných džublaj.
No to nesouvisí,
ale v rámci toho projektu by se to podle
mě ještě jako mělo mělo nařešit
interfinitivně no.
To.
Jenom jako nemáme čistej dopřednej tok.
Aspoň to, co tady vidím teďka.
Potřebujeme,
potřebujeme tohle téma vyřešit aktivně,
prosím?
A neříkám,
že tam jako máš ty a dělat to ty jenom
potřebujeme, aby potřebujeme jako vědět.
A jako.
Já úplně nevim, kdo to má jako vyřešit.
Jo,
jako tak je někdo zodpovědnej za to depol
za provoz toho depa a tohle jsou prostě
podle mě jako lucké faktory,
které jako zlihávají, zlihávají na tom,
co expedujeme a zlihává člověk,
který prostě si vymyslí svou vlastní
jakoby storku a skenuje si, jak chce.
Takže jako víš co?
To bude na každom depe to bude jak pak to
bude v novo bydžové.
To je prostě jako my jsme jim dali jasné
instrukce,
co mají dělat a jestli tam funguje.
Jako každý si to dělá po svém,
tak je těžké,
jako aby tam někdo teďkon budeme sedět 2
týdny.
A co jako za 2 týdny odjedeme a stejně to
nastane tam to musí řídit ten dispečer.
Jo, možná jo, já já neříkám,
kdo to má dělat. Já mu říkám,
to potřebuju takový pevně do rukou,
protože v tuhle chvíli říkám,
je tam 85% k léta expedice.
Tady nebo ještě další diplom?
Tady závěrem patra Martin něco ještě
udělat, nebo?
Závěr je takovej,
že potřebujem dostat ty čísle do nějakého
normálního stavu a já nevím,
jestli teďka jestli teďka to má chytit.
Michal to někdo od Michala ne v Čechách a
jí to vyřešit. Petr čechák, já nevím,
kolik procent těch balíků tady čteme.
89% balíků není systému,
je načten to znamená 10% nebo 10%.
Těch balíků není systémově načtenejch na
svozách to znamená 10% balíku na 1 třídit.
Tak je problém ještě jako IV logistice,
kterej musíme vyřešit.
Kdo má seznam požadavků,
který s tou seznam seznam problémů,
který jsou blbý a kolik nám kolik kolik
tý nekvality vlastně jako dělají?
Jestli 10% je na lidském faktoru,
tak se tam tak se tam jako Ondra chudoba
přestěhoval a má to tam teďka.
Má to tam teďka řešit, je to o tom.
Je to jako o práci s lidma.
Pokud je to o tom,
že my jim tam posíláme blbě palety nebo
blbě načtený blbě načtený lokace,
tak to musíme opravit na logistice.
Jenom potřebuje jakoby v tuhle chvíli od
toho, co slyším,
tak ani jako nemáme seznam těch věcí a
jakým podílem to dopadají.
Já já bych si jako netroufl tvrdit,
že tenhle jako guláš, co se tam odehrává,
tak nám způsobuje jako kvalitu doručení.
Tam to, co i jsem viděl,
jsou jako opakující se problémy,
které mám i na systémových DP.
To jsou to jako mixy,
které nám chodí na 1 sklozech.
Jsou to prostě jako poloprázdné bedny.
Jsou to nějaké jako pozdní dojezdy a
nemusí to mít jako vyloženě souvislost.
Jo oni to, co jsem viděl,
tak oni jako vyjíždějí včas relativně,
ale.
Ta ta efektivita tam prostě není dobrá,
takže ale jako ano,
asi by se to mělo vzít jako Ondra chudoba,
jestli by se měl spojit s vítkem,
kterej má ty bugy.
Potkat se tam projít si to.
Zároveň,
my se s nima potřebujeme jako potkat v té
Plzni hanzaly,
když jsem mu jako vysvětloval,
jak to mají dělat,
on se jako to vůbec neuměl představit.
Prostě Plzni máme účko,
které musí nacouvat dodávka.
Má to tam jako vytřízený už dopředu.
Ten hlavní problém,
kterej se v hosíně odehrává, je ten,
že to tam tříděj řidiči v průběhu,
jak to jezdí v Plzni,
jim to chystá skladník.
Řidič přichází do práce,
má to jako nachystaný, vyřízený.
A jenom si to nakládal do auta.
Což je jako mnohem efektivnější.
Ten řidič tam stráví jako maximálně 34 od
minut jako nevyřešíme jo.
Nevím na koho jste teďka mám koukat.
Nechci se mám koukat na Martinu,
nebo jestli se mám koukat na 2 dobu.
No a Petra čeká taková tak jako kdyby na
bedra na bedra, no celej tobě na petratě.
Podzem.
Se budeme koukat na bedra Martin,
ty sem prostě s betrem spoj jo.
Jo můžu.
Tak ještě můžeš.
Před vámi, kdepak lze tu poštu?
Mikrofon.
Haló haló jo dobrý,
pustili jsme DP poslední x el,
Ano.
máli jsme tam počatočné problémy.
Dneska ještě tam byli špatně čítačelné
bar kódy na bránách,
ale jakoby řeší se to.
Mělo by se to zlepšit s tím,
že tam ještě má dojít k posunu svozu z
původného plánu. 8 30 na 6 30.
Takže jako tohle.
Je tam potřeba dotlačit kamerovej systém.
Vy si to na martinom číž kouským,
ktorého nonstop urguju,
aby doplnil pojmenovaně ty kamer.
Bez toho nám to ajťáci prostě nespustí.
A co se týká a jenom upozorním na
organizační strukturu, je tam špatný.
Ten toho doplnění toho stavu obtěžný
nábor,
takže tam nám to trošku výrazně máme tam
50% stále jenom SHPPA vozíme tam lidi s
chrášťan.
Reporting základny jsme představili ty
reporty a management reporty na základě
domluvy s Hynkem posouváme dál,
potřebujeme splnit 1 giru,
potřebujeme dostat data na DVH abysme se
abysme mohli vytvořit nějaký krajší power
BID report. Tak to má taky v procesu.
Praha.
Jakési zkratka, Plzeň.
3 dřív jo.
Tak jo Martin děkujeme asi,
jestli už musíš jít.
Jo musím, musím, tak jo, mějte se čau.
Tak jo.
Díky.
To znamená.
Mírou nákup manipulačky.
Jo, děkuju.
Já jsem tam přidal.
Tam by to někde mělo být vidět,
tak třeba vede.
Tak nevím ne ty milníky jsme tam při
další,
teda máme plán teď přímo v tom teda
dokonce to je přímo tady lov tom,
dokonce prostě. Června.
Teda ten počet takhle to má metoda
rozjetý.
Abysme měli ač máme čtečka na tiskárny,
jo teda využili ta manipulační technika,
už je teda v procesu,
že Pavla to je tam měla nějaký doplňující
dotaz,
ale manipulační technika už to beru,
že znamená to, že se tady stál.
Co potřebujou třeba nějaký výpočty,
potřebuje teda 46.
Byl tam byly nějaký přesuny a podobně.
Tady to psal nějaký komentář jsem si
všiml, ptal jsi se mároše zaj ulice,
tady to prostě pořád probíhá,
a to máme do konce června si říct ideálně
ty počty,
co chceme koupit za všechny a na
střídáčka.
To jsem si ještě ověřoval u hráče smetana,
že ten jakoby v tečka pořád jako pro nás
má minimálně 200 kusů, jo.
A dneska jsme měli s Filipem používání.
S Tomášem.
A možná to jsme nakoupili i třeba něco
víc, kdyby měli prostě svaz ano takhle,
když to budeme schválně,
takhle uvažujeme taky.
A taky máme ten.
Rozpad teda v pohodě,
to znamená tady někde kolem 01-10 je,
že to všichni budou mít jako na tom plat
a to mi stačí jako v pohodě.
Takhle to ano, tak jsem se ptal.
Teď třeba to musí jako využil nějaký
třískav kašťanek.
Když ta k nám přišla ta sezóna,
že jo v října.
To znamená nápočet,
ještě mají to nějakých 14 dní? Jo,
v podstatě ano,
tak to umíte tam položit OK to objednán.
David,
tady mám takový vždycky nějaký problém,
nebo něco?
Tam se trhne nějaký ty tamhlety třeba
jestli vy vidíte,
tak řekněte čtečky podle 4 nebo todle to
vypadá,
že mína s osobou ty sklady dost dostane
kvízek do 20 6 dáváte dohromady objemy
nebo jako počty?
Z koaliční do dešťů ještě prokladem musí
nějak za tří dílnu,
jestli ty ty milníky teda vycházej tak,
že?
Července vykopneš.
Tendr na ten počítám,
že bude teda měsíc a ten počítáme,
bude trvat víc digitálních žádost,
že jo ještě za tak my máme nabídky,
že jo z loňska ještě od loňského, tak jo,
takže ta potom bude rychlý,
ale jenom tam budeme jenom tam.
Bylo to alternativy levnější,
které tam chce bude.
Vyhod.
To řeším to.
Vyšší a řeší to jo OK?
To znamená 01-10 fakt klasik projedu se
to tam máme jako měsíc.
Na to podám všechno do kupy a já to
skladu opravdu, no spíš asi v 15 15 dní.
Já jsem si to neseděla nějaká místa,
jinak teda 1 tejden.
A to jsem se ještě dneska ptal do toho na
tomhle že jo jsou ty bedny,
tak to asi vypadá,
že potřeba něco domluvit.
To se taky natočí a tam to asi není
takový tlak na to,
že to může být třeba měsíc pozornost.
A tam potom taky benetrolný a potom obce,
případně kdybysme se rozhodli,
jako měla třeba lobko měla,
že jo byla jakým způsobem tam to vypadá,
že nějakej čas rozhodnout,
jestli chceme další black nějaký obci od
toho?
No řekli si nějaké počty s berem,
který potřebujou? Nevím,
sice prostě velký ano AAA řekli si rovnou.
Hele, běž, tak úplně přesně víme,
takže vezmem určitě nějaký množství lidí,
který chceme třeba 50000 dám příklad jo a
dalších 40 třeba teď bude potřebovat,
tak vám vyhrazeme právo se jako
rozhodnout do nějakýho okamžiku,
třeba někdy v září určitě dodavateli,
že řekneme potvrzené, chceme i 40,
anebo nechceme mít, nebo chceme 20.
Operátoři OK to byl problém, prodávám,
je prosím nějaký termín?
Že tam byla jako nějaká ob carda,
jako že na letu,
že máme jako obci ne loni jana rudská
projektů,
protože úplně přesně na nějaký čas jsme
věděli, kolik potřebují veden,
takže třeba řekli,
hele 150 to tak nevíme třeba bungbu a
jste si dohodli, že by potenciálně,
kdybychom se ukázali,
tak potřebuji tu 2 půlku těch dalších 50,
takže bude tam nějaká jako obce,
jako nějaký právo, že jo,
potřebujeme na začátek prostě sama,
že bude připravený třeba jo.
Takže my to potřebujete relativně v 1.
Roce, že jo?
Takže si řekneme, chceme tohle typy,
dodává.
To jo že takže doberem najednou všechno a
když to jako v čase rozdělíme,
případně s nějakým generálním faktem,
bych se rozhodli,
že nechceme tu 2 půlku tak prostě
nekoupíme.
Jo.
Proč ještě s rukou jako šli na tu
chatristiku, ale vím,
že tam jako obci měli,
případně si řekli jako že nebo ji nechce
vůbec. My jsme tam přišli,
tak ušetřili třeba jo i takhle něco
takovýho stojí, že to je asi všechno.
A tady máš nějaký červený Franta srdečněr
a termíny tady prostě,
co to je tady červený?
Pojďte do toho nepřešli máme,
nebo je představování vlastně může zavřít,
a to zavřu, nebo jestli to je radit,
jak se zavři jestli,
nebo tam je nějaké ještě třeba frantíka
tady něco čekáš,
tak se ještě asi František,
to je to co chápu to co se z Lucka, to je,
co chtěli objednat.
Chápu tak jenom teďka tam na tebe,
tak jenom, jestli se nejověstíš,
nebo proč tohle jo,
to je taky výpočty a to jo, jo,
tak tady prostě nějaký červený.
Ta.
Dobře.
Děkujeme, děkujeme.
Tak půjdeme dál,
půjdeme teda podle standardního.
Mohl bych taky. To se Michaela děkuju.
R máčko, hele,
já jsem z nějakých jako časových důvodů
dal projekt,
teda mi status do té raversky evno je to
ale úzce spojený,
případně vám můžu ještě před ale prosím.
Tam je tam je čerstvej update to je
naprosto no.
A jí prostě než pravý rem a nějak jo jako
teoreticky hele řešíme to už jsme se
teďka jako dostali do stavu,
kdy tyhle 2 projekty řešíme zároveň.
S provozákama s procesákama jakermáčka
tak tak logistiky a běží to souběžně
hlavně kvůli té infrastruktuře,
ale i tomu budoucímu napojení těch
jednotlivých procesů.
Co se stalo v minulém týdnu,
byl to docela fičák,
nicméně výstup je takový.
Že odcepeny máme schválenou.
Celou cenovou nabídku na realizaci
elektřiny a internetu dneska začala
realizace na místě.
Už si to tam vedoucí s cepeny od nás od
nás ten prostor převzal.
Zítra tam začnou navážet materiál odhad
je 14 dnů s tím, že.
Jsou z toho trošku vydivočení a plánujou.
Plánujou to tam jako pracovat IV noci.
Od co je důležitý, tak je,
že jsme ještě v minulém týdnu přišli na
to, že centrální switche,
které měly být použity původně ze sence,
tak použity z esence být nemůžou,
jelikož zenc je stále nějakým způsobem v
takovém jako pohotovostním provozu.
A tím pádem jsme potřebovali urychleně
objednat nové switche tady jako díky.
Mírově kavarimus se nám to jako podařilo
rychle schválit, rychle objednat.
Dneska jsme se sešli s Luckou váňovou,
AS Michalem urbancem s it ve zdibech.
Procházeli jsme ty ty jednotlivé
pracoviště, aby věděli, co je čeká,
kolik budou potřebovat a pček a podobně.
Neměl by tam být jako žádný problém a
jakmile bude mít cepel a hotovo,
tak v rámci jako jednotek dnů nám to tam
it it oživit.
Michal urbanec si to vzal na sebe bude
ještě v rámci jako layoutu jednotlivých
skladů procházet,
co tam vlastně jako vůbec všechno je?
Co tam není,
protože po skladu no tak jako it má ty
layouty na každý sklad zvlášť a kde jaké
AP, kde je kamera a podobně.
Takže tohle on si tohle on si projde,
protože tohle na místě úplně jako
nezjistil.
Nicméně co se týče té infrastruktury, tak.
Tady je to vesměs pozitivní.
Nyní teda v rukou cepenek.
David musí čekat,
až přijdou bysme nasvědče musí čekat.
Šťourka váňováno ano,
ano a ty ty switche switche je objednanej,
měl by byl objednanej v pátek pátýho a
měl by dorazit do 14 dnů.
To znamená někdy jako 19 až 22.
Něco takovýho jo,
takže tady nám to jako relativně
relativně sedí.
A nebo třeba sme přijdete a kam ho někam
daj do toho reku přesně tak.
Přesně tak,
na to už se dneska díval někam to budou
dávat,
tak to budou zapojovat tahat optiku a.
Takže toliko KK elektřině AK internetu
vyznačíte nějaké více peněz? Jo,
k tomu se k tomu se dostanu a ještě jenom
jako infrastruktura pro pokračuje tam
výběr kol na dodavatele stlačeného
vzduchu, protože 1.
Dodavatel byl za produment nevyhovující z
důvodu ceny.
Si tam jako byla napálená docela cena,
to znamená teďka vlastně Honza.
Šimáček řeší 2 dodavatele,
abychom měli porovnání,
což je jako nad slunce jasné,
že se to jako nestihne ke konci měsíce a
jsou tam jako 2 důvody. 1 důvody je,
že ještě nemáme celou nabídku a vůbec to
nemáme schválený od toho 2 dodavatele 2
důvod je,
že instalace stlačeného vzduchu se bude
dělat.
Na připravenou infrastrukturu od cepeny
na ty žulaby se pravděpodobně budou.
Přikecovat, ty, přikecovat ty trubky,
takže oni stejně jako můžou začít až
potom, co bude mít srpen a hotovo.
Nicméně jako pro rma to není problém.
Jsou schopni dočasně fungovat s tím
stlačeným vzduchem v těch sprejch,
které normálně jako naloze prodáváme.
A to máte na očištění jako jo přesně tak
je to rád jako.
Vládci telefon na tyhlety věci.
Ono samozřejmě tohle to řešení je jako
dlouhodobě ekonomické, jako výhodnější,
než než se stahovat ty spreje ale
nějakých jako 14 dní.
S tím jsme schopni jako v pohodě přežít.
Jo,
takže tohle je ke stlačenému vzduchu a
možná ještě teda info ke kamerám.
Tam jsme minulý týden seděli s Martinem
žižkovským,
kterej si ty layouty teďka jako vzal,
aby spočítal počet potřebných kamer.
Říkal, že.
Spoustu jich máme jako k dispozici někde.
Takže takhle ten člověk jo je,
je to vlastně jako podřízenej webkovi? Jo,
ne,
to je nějakej jako šéf a on je tady
relativně nově.
OKA licentu máme editce jo to co jsme
jako řešili, že že by byl problém,
byl přechod na tu na tu většinu na ten
software a vy jste nicméně tam to Martin
jako chce realizovat až společně s
lékárnou a dalšími projekty,
které jako ve zdi bude mají vzniknout.
A když nebudete mít připuštění,
je to problém ne. Není to problém.
Budou tam ty kamery tak jak jsme si je
navrhli na současných softwarech.
A údajně jako nemá být problém.
S tím je pak jenom jako switchnout na
jiný software. Jo,
takže pro nás tohleto jako teďka problém
neznamená.
Martin si akorát do budoucna bude muset
řešit nějaké jako tendr na ten na ten
avigion,
protože to bude asi drahá legrace pro
celé s tím je přechod hlavně bude těžké.
Jo, hele, já jsem, já jsem mu jako říkal,
že já tady na tohleto nechci spoléhat,
protože 1 se mi potřeboval mutikamer jako
fungovalo jako 1 adgio nebo co to je?
A parťákem byl třeba jenom na tom pacient,
někdo tam někdo všiml nebo jako Honza
Šimáček už tam mají přímo jako svojeho
projekťáka a svého vedoucího,
protože ta výhoda cesta je,
že vám k tomu rovnou potom zpracuji
projektovou dokumentaci,
takže oni si to tam jako řídí,
plus tam jsou provozáky. Provozáci Franta,
srdečný a terka jako ještě možná teda
zpráva k těm datům já ještě pojedu.
Jinak je mi svědkem.
V pondělí vyslovil přání.
Ono my potom budeme po přeplně,
což platí potom pro všechny.
Ty se jako týká,
který mají ty datový potřeby a datový
instalace proměřit jakoby tu konektivitu,
že jo,
jak tam tečou ty data proměřit je tedy,
že to jako funguje?
To každá zásuvka má být proměřená,
že tam jako teče šťáva v nějakým jako
rychlosti objemu nevím.
A typicky dám to dělá dodavatele ten,
kterej to instaloval.
Protokol měření a míra míra prostě
referený požadavek. Požadavek,
že by chtěl,
aby tam někdo někdo jinej nějaká jiná
firma.
Třeba 2 firma.
Jaká byla firma,
to znamená cena být nezávislý měření,
jasně nezávislá kontrola toho,
že to udělá,
to je pro vás tady pro všechny,
teda do pléna,
že v rámci těch protokolů přidávají všech
a podobně.
Budeme chtít měření od nějaké 2 entity to
nějaké 2 jiné firmy? OK,
se dá nám to proměřit a fakt předávám
tuhle info shi mimu, aby si to zařídil.
Věřím,
že nějaké revizáky jako obecně máme to
samé to na procházky AV podstatě.
Neviděl de facto týden asi teda.
Ale primárně teda Michal na Lucka,
no jo OKA.
Podle mě s tím případně můžu poradit.
Já nevím,
někdo si ten urbanec nebo tak podat,
jak věděli já jako vůbec nevim,
co to obnáší. Jo, tohle to nevím,
kolik to stojí peněz a tak dále,
ale samozřejmě budu tam děláme jako.
Datazána půl.
Dobrý vědět,
tak tam jde asi o tu elektřinu.
Prostě to celé jako střepnout nezávisle,
protože tím oni je pak taková píšu
cokoliv, že jo jasně,
no a my si toho jako neuvěříme, OK,
ještě tím nějak potřeba i pomoct,
tak mi dáme na hlavě dohromady tady jako
nová situace, nová směna.
A jo takhle upřímná,
že jsme to ještě nikdy jako tady nedělali.
Vždycky nám to mělo ten,
kdo nám to instaloval jasně,
což ale v současné době bylo otazníky.
Tak.
Takže proto?
Někdo jinej OK,
je to novej stav a nějak se s tím musíme
teda popasovat.
OK jo není možné,
aby tam byl protokol od té cerát
instalovaný jasně.
To bylo jako předčasný jo,
dobře prostě správně neměli,
neměli jako převrat.
Tak tohle,
co se týče infrastruktury víceméně jako
ten spárů událostí, byl takový,
že včera jsme jim potvrdili, že vyhráli.
A oni jako řekli OK, tak mi zítra začnem,
to znamená teďka.
Reverzní logistika,
respektive Franta srdečný zajistil
vyklizení toho prostoru.
A byly tam ještě nějaké jako lednice,
takže to to,
že je vyklizený během dnešního dne,
tam vyznačují pracoviště.
Stejně tak to RA.
Tam ten prostor byl předpřipravený a
dneska už tam probíhá vyznačení pracovišť,
aby věděli, kde se to,
kde se to bude zapojovat.
Který.
Antila jsou tady no.
Pátek budeme mít v pátek budeme mít
finální zadání na změnu toho zpětného
toku. Co se týče dopravního nastavení.
A co ještě důležité zmínit,
tak v pátek bude probíhat pro reverzní
logistiku od Andrew kremra systémové
testování na jednotlivé procesy,
které se tam mají odehrávat.
Jestli nám tam všechno funguje,
nebo jestli tam nevyply na nějaký nějaký
bug?
Jo tak nějak testovací databázi nebo tak?
Petr areálu.
Areálu.
Tak zároveň už jsme připravili
harmonogram přesunu společně s provozem a
procesem. A to co?
Vás tam jako nejvíc trápí,
tak je samozřejmě přesný deadline toho,
kdy ta infrastruktura bude dokončená,
rozšířená,
protože od toho se pak jako ty ty návazné
úkoly budou odehrávat. To znamená,
máme teďka jako mustr a ve velmi krátké
době si tam jako potřebujeme doplnit
datum, ke kterým to směřujeme,
protože není to jenom o tom fyzickém
přesunu,
ale IO tom jako nastavení těch těch toho
zpětného toku z pohledu doprav,
kdy ti procesáci taky předem potřebujou
vědět.
Datum,
kdy už to má začít jezdit jako do
třídírny a ne do chrášťan.
Tady potom to berte kolečkované ale bere
q.
Souvisí.
Jo q já nevím jestli tady je to.
Tím tady jseš tady tome.
Tady je jo,
já jsem tam psal koment to víceméně je.
To se může jako od odfignout jediné,
co se tam jako řešil,
nějaký jako problém na gejtách,
ale to nebylo jako nic zásadního.
Takže.
Takže to je to hotový nebo není teda?
Hotový není spíš z něho,
sešlo bych řekl takhle,
že jako ty jsi tam odehrávali,
tak jsme nastavení nemají ty prava,
Tak tak bych to taky řekl, no.
tak OK, tak co prosím tě?
Asi teda nechám přímo komentář a zabral.
Jo, jo, to nechám na jo.
Tady prostředníků.
Dotaz.
Minule minulý týden jsi říkal.
Riziko 1 7 riziko byla cena.
Tak.
Teď říkáme 1 setkání není ohrožených.
No neni ohroženy za předpokladu,
že splní to, co slíbila,
že na realizaci potřebujou 14 dnů.
Pokud tohle cepena dodrží,
tak známe ještě jako pár dnů časovou
rezervu.
I včetně jako instalace a oživení našim
našim it na místě,
ale už si můžu normálně spravit ne jako
do do bloků.
Tohle je všechno nahrnuto tam jako ne
postupně, ale to se toho se nebojím.
Já se spíš bojím toho procesního
nastavení doprav,
protože to musíš jako 1 dni prostě
zaříznout.
A teď ti ty věci jako začnou chodit do
třídírny a ve chvíli,
kdy tam začnou chodit a ty je nemáš kde
zpracovat.
Tak ti tam vzniká beglog jo a tomuhle.
Tomu se chci ideálně jako vyvarovat,
proto by bylo fajn to mít odladěný.
Babička, když ten třeba dokončí,
tak pak ten máte fakt jako jednotky to
dotunit a pak 1 překvapu z celkem rád
bych chvilknout šmejd no.
Tak ještě 1 dotaz mám.
1 7 8 ráno přednáš.
Dopředu beru nastavení ty svozy,
takže se to jako vytvoří nějaký buffr a
chráč a nějaký to bude postupně opadat.
A to co ti zbyde nachráně,
na které stížnost pracovat,
tak ty to přepneš až potom,
co to zpracuješ a nebo převezeš.
Dám se do h monogramu.
Spíš jako otázka,
jestli si to máte vyřešený, nebo nemáte?
Tam se počítá s tím, že se to převeze,
to nezpracujou.
Králšťani sporác.
Tam.
Jo,
ale my tady máme jako alibisticky obě
varianty.
David ho bere by měl být jako za úkol
zpracovat toho co nejvíc jako v
krášťanech.
Vypne se to a pokud tam něco zbyde,
tak to, co zbylo, převezeno.
Takhle byste řekl nezpracovaný stejně tak
no,
stejně tak jako rma tam rozhodně zbyde a
rozhodně se převedejte. To rozhodně zbylý.
Ono to jako přebývá ještě,
nebo člověk se to vlastně jakoby jenom ty
časté cesty a pak se to začne zpracovat
přesně.
Je potřeba něco učit zákazníkovi
komunikovat vůči zákazníkovi pro reversku?
Ne. Pro rma rozhodně ano,
musí se všude upravit informace,
kam nám zákazník může posílat reklamaci a
odstoupení, když ho posílá poštou.
Tahle komunikace je navázaná na všechny
jako emailové šablony na alzí roboty a
podobně. Tohle má na starost holčina.
Která se to všude jako budefinovala s
Martinem kojítkem řeší úpravu.
A zároveň tady,
jako se připravujeme na to, že že dneska,
když vložíš reklamaci do alza boxu,
tak říkáme, děkujeme. Vím,
že jsi vložil za 3 dny, ti dáme vědět,
jak jsme to zpracovali a dáme ti vědět
další postup. Jo,
a ten ty 3 dny je ten g mezitím uloženo
do lazaboxu versus zpracováno na skladě a
my si tohleto jako natáhneme teďka na 5,
abychom zákazníkovi neslibovali něco,
co slíbit, ale zároveň.
Taky nemůžeme třeba volat.
Jo zároveň je to KPI,
které budeme sledovat.
Tak, já už jsem se,
jestli potřeboval něco ošetřit jako 5 dní
a potom případně najít flinu dát nějak
odkazme že a tím říkají,
když budou volat na jo,
kde přes to tejden, kde to Harry byl div,
že ti řeknou něco? Jo?
Jo jo call centrum dostane informace
super.
Takže za mě takto ale děkuje, děkujeme.
Trpenou, která drží palce na.
Já toběžím s dovolením s tak zrovna ten
prosím tě provoz VLCU.
4 7.
Ahoj.
A.
No,
já tady dneska úplně nemám moc
pozitivních věcí. Jediný,
co bych vypíchla,
že došly tiskárny a to je tak asi jediné,
co je jako pozitivní.
Jinak se tam snažíme vyřešit problém s
tím gemem s tím crossováním.
Nemáš to schválně?
Přišli.
Slyšíme se.
Ano ano,
takže ne ne došli jakože došel počet
tiskáren ale došli doc.
Dorazili.
Já jsem taky pochopil, že jako došli,
že nejsou jo.
Ne ne, ne, ne, ne,
ale jako plynule přejdou vod nákupu.
Drobnýho hardwaru na tu manipulační
techniku. Ačkoliv tady jsme slyšeli,
že je všechno bez problémů,
tak o víkendu nám odešly 2 VN áčka.
1 je v opravě to 2 už je mimo provoz a
potřebovali jsme tam urychleně dostat
dostat ty nový.
S tím,
že a tam se dostanu k rizikám jo s tím,
že jako aktuálně prostě ta dodací doba je
4 měsíce a dýl,
takže tady určitě vidím riziko,
ale jdeme k těm pozitivním.
Tak dokupy tiskárny máme,
snažíme se vyřešit to krosování,
jak jsem už tady avizovala asi měsíc
zpátky máme problémy prostě s gemem.
Aktuálně je tam nějaká cenová nabídka.
Na stole probíhá projednání tý ceny,
ale je potřeba prostě řešit tu situaci,
takže aktuálně proběhne testování k
hlasování direktů přes.
Tříděnu cz CT jedničku.
Co se bude zkoušet otevřené body,
opět nám tam vyskočili.
Objednávky XPO,
který směřujou na chrášťany.
Jsem to.
To je cvičené,
jo nám to skončilo nahoru jo.
Zase to skočilo nahoru.
Čili tak já jsem jí dal.
Poslední týdny je to zvýšené.
Tak poslední týden je to zvýšený.
Já jsem to minulý týden otevřela s Ondrou
Tady.
danešem s tím, že on řekl, že se dají,
že si prostě udělají KP etu sledovat na
týdenní bázi, ale ten detail k tomu nevím,
takže se potřebuji spojit znova s ondro
danišem a říct si vůbec,
co teda tam sledujou,
jako jestli tam něco probíhá,
nevím davide asi nevíš, David.
A máš k tomu nějaký detail?
Ne ne, ne, ne, ne nemám, nemám.
Co jsem se bála.
Každopádně ty objednávky nám tam dostali
nahoru, ASPD už mě ignoruje,
takže tady tady bohužel ten detail k tomu
nemám.
S Honzou horáčkem to Ježíš nebo s kým to
tam řešíš?
S Honzou horáčkem a Honza si myslím,
že je ten druhej tak.
My jsme se bavili o tom,
že tam je udělaný domluvený s mírou
nějaký výjimky dodavatelů,
který údajně jako můžou jít můžou jít do
chrášťan.
Ty.
A já jsem v životě ten seznam těch email
neviděl.
Neexistuje, a Honza Horáček řekl,
že ho dělat nebude.
Na základě toho jsme se právě domluvili s
Ondrou dálničím,
že se dají počet jakoby přijmutých
expelček, že se dají do toho,
že se dají do KPI, ale vůbec netuším,
jaká je ta hodnota. Nevím to,
že se potřebuji spojit s Ondrou.
Tak a jdeme k rizikům.
Gem tam stále vidíte,
jenom jsem tady říkala,
Ano.
probíhá teďkon nějaký cenový jednání.
Aktuálně se bavíme, září, říjen termín.
Pokud to klapne, je tady to VNA.
Jak jsem říkala,
o víkendu jim odešli 2 VA.
Přál jsem si dneska s Pavlou tu výběrku
běží do zítra by měl mít všechny cenový
nabídky.
Na začátku července by se mělo rozhodnout,
teda, kdo bude vítěz.
A pak je tam dodací doba po 4 měsíce jo,
což je dost velký jako riziko prosazeno,
takže já se zkusím domluvit s Pavlou,
Titulky.
jestli fakt si můžem,
jestli máme prostě všechny.
Všechny cenový nabídky,
nebo respektive k zítřku budeme mít
všechny cenový nabídky, jestli je nutný,
tam pak nechávat další 3 tejdny a jako.
Vybrání výběr prostě vítěze jo,
takže to je v řešení a.
Pak jsme tam měli milník vlastně k 36 na
přesun zbytku XP.
K bazaru a petu z chrášťá do užijec a
tady nám aktuálně užit se hlásili,
že jsou plný jo,
bavíme se o nějakých šestceti metrech
kubickejch.
Takže teďkon taky,
musíme se na to podívat s Tomem,
co s tím dál.
Tom tam měl nějaký 3 3 návrhy řešení.
Ale hlásili nám včera, že jsou plný.
Jo je pravda že teď jsme v nějakém peaku.
Ta zásoba je vysoko probíhá nějaký
výprodej, ale k třicátýmu 6 ti to.
Nejenom pocitově.
Pocitově dobře.
To je pocitovka ve stejně.
Dobře.
Takže řešení?
Tak do teďka jsme měli dobrej pocit.
David říká, že to je pocitový, no je,
je to prostě v řešení.
Dneska jsme jako dneska jsme si to
otevřeli.
S Tomem říkám tu informaci máme teď,
nevím,
jestli od včerejška nebo od konce
minulýho týdne, že se nevejdou,
takže se na to potřebujem podívat.
A co s tím?
OK to mám ten termín 1 7 tak potom tady v
milicích si asi potom šoupneš tady tohle.
Jo domluvíme se,
co s tím ať tam zase nedávám nějaký
Tak jo.
hausnumera AA dáme tam nějakej reálnej,
jestli počkáme chvilku, zjistíme,
Normálně.
jak je potřeba ta plocha v chrášťanech
davide u tebe a řekneme si,
jestli to tam může ještě chvilku zůstat,
nebo jestli to přesunou třeba do do do l
cz k. Nevím, teď teď nevím.
Mně už tady mně už tady to zaplaťpánbůh
moc nezůstalo.
Takže jako zatím mi to nevadí.
Jako my taky potřebujeme,
Já bych.
aby dodělali tu stavbu a zabalili jsme
začít stavět regály a.
Jo.
Začít naskladňovat, ale to.
Spíš potřebujem udělat tam ten příjem,
tam to blokuje ten příjem no.
To je to, ten je podle mě dole na zemi,
ne?
No ten pat už tam není.
Je vyklizené.
To už to už my už máme i zbourané ty
regály tam to všechno jede a teď jenom
Rozdělaný.
hledám místo, kam to dát,
protože všichni mě posílají do patřičných
míst.
Tak jestli nám to neblokuje ten prostor
dole na zemi,
kterej teďka Lucka potřebuje,
aby tam mohla postavit ten příjem a tys
to dala nahoru.
Nahoru jo do patra.
Tady k tomu.
Teď ti moc nerozumím.
Ten, kterej si říkal, že nebo co,
co tam zbejvá těch 600m a ten bazar,
tak si přesunul nahoru do toho XPO.
Do do mezerinu.
No já mám takovej blbej dojem,
že jsem to poslal do užic.
Takže už to tam nemaj.
Nebo CI 600 kubíků.
Co se týče toho patu,
tak v krásných je teďka nějakých třeba 25
kubíků jenom už.
Těch 600 to je prostě balíček,
celý toho XPO to znamená všechno ostatní
kromě petu.
OK, ale tak to je to znamená, to je to,
co je nahoře v těch.
Ano.
Tim patrew.
Asi možná bude něco i ve VA, nevim.
No ale.
Ale to,
co máš těch patrech jo v tom 2 patře tak
to je ale SPO nebo BPO ne.
Ten ten tady zůstává.
Ty pytlíky.
Jo jo ale tam je to expiovačka moje
expivačkou.
Jo ale tak Tomáš to je 1 dlouhá nudle
podíl z dějí.
A já si taky myslím to tam ještě teďka
jako můžeme, případně zůstat no.
Jo určitě.
OK, děkujeme, takže řeším, máme.
Hele a já se ještě jenom vrátím.
Já jsem si odběhnul zeptat se jenom
rychle vedlej kluků,
jako zase to nějaká pocitovka ohledně tý
distribuce toho XPO, ale kluci říkají,
jako že přes nás jde minimum tak jako na
základě čeho vy to sledujete?
Jo.
Já nevím kolik je 150 kusů balet jo,
ale bude to podle mě jako 20 palet.
Jo dobrý, dobrý, už jsem doma.
Posypáme jako.
Hele ale tak jako já můžu říct,
když mi to dodavatel přiveze,
ať s tím jde do toho do šípku a prostě mu
to nevezmu a je pokoj.
Ať si SPD pak dělá co chce.
To byla původní domluva a pak vznikla
tady nějaká nepsaná dohoda mezi SPDA
mírou a ten detail,
jako je takový hodně shrey.
Terko pojďme se domluvit s tím Ondrou.
Jestli jestli ta Ondra má nějakou domluvu
teďka ZSPD, tak jí nerušme,
Jo jo jo.
ať nejsme my ty co porušilo domluvit,
pojďme se domluvit s Ondrou,
kolik na to maj času a když to zvládnou,
tak to zvládnou. Když to nezvládnu,
to navíc začne otáčet.
Jo.
OK.
Super děkujeme, takhle děkujeme,
pojedeme dál.
Taky.
Tak miku poprosím tě destrukce
technologie materiálu.
A.
Destrukce technologie a materiálu.
Tam jsme se posunuli jenom lehounce a to
v tom smyslu, že místo projekťák,
kterého jsme tam měli získat,
tak mi dneska říkal pan vozár,
že to bude řešit on přímo s námi,
protože ten jejich projekťák je někde
zasekaný v Polsku.
A co se týče dalších kroků,
tak máme mustr seznamu,
do kterého přepisujeme ty naše seznamy
věcí, které chceme prodávat na pondělí,
máme naplánovanou schůzku s panem vozárem.
Abychom ten seznam prošli a měli bychom
to začít nadávat už konečně do toho
adlasu.
Co se týče nějaký toho nějakýho toho key
YC, což je ověřování toho,
jestli jsme spolehlivej partner pro ten
prodej,
jestli za utržené peníze nekupujeme
zbraně a tak podobně,
tak to prý může probíhat zároveň s tím,
co budem už jako mít 1 aukci spuštěnou.
Jenom na okraj ještě míra k tomu všemu,
co řešíme.
Tady v českých skladech tak přihodil
exteráky.
Respektive rušení externích skladů na
Slovensku a budeme prodávat i nějaký věci
právě z těhletěch exteráků.
To asi ve zkratce takhle všechno k tomu,
co se co se událo toho minulýho týdne.
To znamená,
tohle se nám vidět trošku posouvá ne key
To se nám trošku posouvá.
Termíny zatím nechávám starý,
c atlas.
já nevím jako na na jaký je dávat,
ale spíš aby to na nás svítilo červeně,
Okay.
že už jsme to dávno měli udělat,
nebo dávno měli obdržet. Jo.
Nechám být max tou jo.
Děkuji.
Úžasný děkujeme.
Tak.
Lud škodeme na tebe,
respektive Martin Lucka výtlak z
autostoru. Podělíte se asi na půl tam.
Jo, jo, podělíme.
Tak za moji část tolik se nám toho
nestalo,
Tak asi Martin.
jelikož se soustředil především na jiný
projekty.
Co se týče obecně autostoru jako takovýho
s Pavlem Růžičkou a Pavlem ročákem se nám
podařilo zprovoznit 1 prototyp USB
tlačítka na porty.
Mám to aktuálně nachráštěnech budu to
testovat pravděpodobně v pátek,
pokud mi zbyde čas. Pokud ne,
tak někdy příští týden. V případě,
že toto bude OK,
tak můžem víceméně rovnou objednávat,
objednávat hardware.
Na SKC trojku i naráštěny pro.
Pro, nový porty jako takový.
Co se týče dalších věcí s Lukášem tom
jsou a jeho tým,
jak jsme si stanovili finální deadline,
instalaci drobného hardwaru.
Většinou už máme na chrášťanech teďka
jenom bojím se o kapacitou deadline jsme
si stanovovali na 17. 7.
Kdyby mělo být všechno nainstalované z
další věcí,
společně s Davidem hubrem a honzíkem
zapletalem ladíme ajíčkovi nitový daily
reporty, na který jsme pracovali.
A postupně to vyladili do nějaké řekněme
finální finální betoverzi,
kterou budeme pracovat.
S elementem jsme se dohodli na updatu
autostoru nejnovější verzi v rámci v
rámci chrášťan termínově nikdy.
Ke konci června by to mělo být,
čímž díky tomu bude na stejné verzi na
nějaký aktuální je DSKLC trojka.
Což by nám mělo přinést nějaký nový,
drobnější funkce a tak dále.
Co se dalších věcí s anetou pracujem na
na modulu pro AS reporting.
Taháme si aktuálně zdrojový data a
prokopáváme si ty základní cesty,
kudy budeme tahat pro ty 2 základní MRON
modlely. Jen kdyžtak vidí,
to by potřeboval a zbytek času jsem
především strávil na přípravě discovery
eventu,
který bude příští čtvrtek a zároveň jsem
si dělal brainstorming.
Na téma řízení autostore v sezóně a
nějaký daily daily czech upy.
Jak budou probíhat?
Tolika se za mě za mě k autostoru.
Co se událo?
Hm.
A já si vezmu tu svojí část,
tak co se týče stavební přípravy,
tak dneska jsme konečně obdrželi nabídku
na elektro watchapeny.
Ta cena je nějakých milion a půl korun,
aleš,
nebo jsme s Alešem domluvený přes Pavlu,
že budeme tu cenu chelengovat,
aleš tam vidí,
že by tam mohla bejt úspora nějakejch
200000.
Co se týče datových sítí,
tak tam máme hotové zadání.
Včera jsme to tam s cepenou procházeli.
Čekáme na nabídku. Tvrdí,
že by měla být do pátku.
Zajímavý.
Schválili jsme si s provozem i salamentem
layout, kde budou uskladňovat materiál,
element a co se týče 1 takovýho jako
možnýho rizika nebo relativně nové
informace,
nástup pro malou bude pravděpodobně
posunut o 3 dny na čtvrtek 25. S tím,
že realizace je 10 až 12 pracovních dní.
Dneska my ještě po telefonu potvrzoval,
že by to měli určitě stihnout,
případně ještě prověřujou možnosti.
Že by pracovali v sobotu.
Tam jsme jim ten deadline my jsme jim
dali deadline desátýho 6 ale víme,
Tolik.
Jo.
že tam ještě máme jako týden buffr ale
deadline pro ně máme desátýho 7 teda.
Já bych jim doporučoval makat IV neděli
jako.
Zrovna promanu ty jo OK ale dobrý.
Já se zeptám lucko asi asi jasně 25 6 10
je to nějakýho pátýho šestýho?
Cirka sedmýho osmýho no.
A to pravděpodobnost pětadvacátýho,
tak to už je jako potvrzený,
nebo teprve jako indikujou.
To je teďka pod 3 dny.
Volal mi asi před 2 hodinama,
že to obdržel jako novou informaci,
že se zdržej na předchozí realizaci a
nebudou moct nastoupit to pondělí a že to
pravděpodobně bude čtvrtek,
ale že to ještě potvrdí.
Nebo nějaký přípravný práci?
Jestli budeme poslat nějakej část
machoftu?
Co.
No to nemoh no.
Tam máme trošku svazaný ruce,
no tam prostě ty montážníky,
A ty.
co co měli naplánovaný,
že pošlou v pondělí,
tak ještě je potřebujou.
Tak to plánoval ten barevný člověče.
Ale myslím si jako že ta sobota je jako
vstřícnost, protože.
Hele a.
Když jsme se na to ptali jako poprvý,
někdy jsme po něm chtěli harmonogram a
jestli by mohli dělat případně o sobotách
nebo prodloužit si směry,
tak nejdřív napsali, že jako absolutně ne,
že to neplánujou. Asi teďka říkal,
jako že že to prověřuje jako možnost,
že si myslíš, že by to šlo.
Aby se to stihlo.
Tak on má teď dost maso na hlavě? Jo,
to neberu jako zřícenej krok,
To.
ale on si teďkon jako zachraňuje svůj
zadek, takže já mockrát mu píšu.
Všechno jo nebo píšeš mu nebo?
Jo píšou mu,
já jsem od něj právě chtěla ten na sobě
harmonogram,
takže on mi dneska poslal jako s tím,
že vlastně jsou v pohodě,
že celkem těch 12 pracovních dní a
zpoždění se vůbec nezmínil. Jo,
takže je dobrý. Předpokládám,
že ta klucka říká,
volal jí 2 hodiny zpátky,
ale on na to reagovat.
A to je písemně no mám takový jako
dežalycky z promanentní, no dobře.
Tohle jako to.
No,
já to chci právě všechno písemně a tohle
je prostě jako tohle není v pohodě.
Hele a ten smluvní vztah bude nějak
ošetřený. Nevím nějak jako písemně,
nebo jak to vlastně teďka bude jenom,
nebo je objednávka jenom jak to,
jak to jde namyšlený?
Máme objednávku mailem,
kterou udělala Pavla a vrátilo se nám,
že potvrzujou termín,
že realizace začne dvaadvacátýho 6 nic
jinýho jakoby nemáme.
S Pavlou jsme to řešili. Pavla říkala,
že takhle, jakoby je to dostatečný za ní.
Jo, a když budou posílat nějaký penále,
můžeme vymáhat, případně.
No říkala,
že jako všechno podle občanskýho zákoníku.
Takže stejně by nám to moc jako asi
nepomohlo,
protože to bude by to nějakou dobu trvalo
tenhle ten proces.
Ok.
Jo OK jenom my se ptám,
jestli to případně potvrzený nebo
odpochycený,
když vy náhodou se stalo něco jako
nesprávného.
Dobře OK,
takže schůma sumádu elektro OK datovka
čekáš elektru.
To přece dan tady drahého,
že loni teďka koukám na loňskou přípravu.
Já vím,
že to je teďka jako v tunelu a venku.
Zleva ty porty, to je jako na 2 místech,
ale to dvakrát víc než dvakrát,
tak dražší, skoro třikrát tak dražší.
Když to bylo loni loni to bylo za 580000
teďka to je za milion a půl.
Hele je to tady,
je to tady rozdělený na několik částí 1.
Ta část je demontáž,
následná montáž světel tam jsme čekali na
tu nabídku,
jestli to udělají oni tu demontáž,
nebo poprosíme údržbu.
Tam se ještě potřebujeme,
potřebujeme teda domluvit,
jestli to bude dělat údržba,
nebo to udělá to sepena,
pak je tady navýšení kapacity rozvaděče
RT 2 1 to je za nějakých 550000.
OKA ty.
Pak je k tomu posunutí posunutí rozvaděče
ve 2. Patře, to je za nějakých 30000.
To je jakoby relativně drobný.
Pak jsou tady přívody pro pro nové
nabíječky. Ty jsou za 220.
Přívody pro roboty k tunelu za 400000 a
přívody pro západ za 300.
Potřeba ty světla to za kolik jste
nacenili ty světla převěšení?
Hele samotnou demontáž si nacenili na 7 a
půl 1000.
Do roku 1000 let.
OK no nic no ty dohody jsou to není jako
práce,
zase přijdou zbrojit a to je prostě k pet.
Nové stránky byly rozvedený,
tak to je pozice rozhodně velká.
Už to jako tolik bavit,
tam je pozice volná ta vodíš jistič.
Myslím,
že to tak nějak pofunguje množství a
minulej rok ten náklad na ten roz svoje
případné spadl dovopinku,
proto ho tady nevidím. To bylo taky nějak?
Jo, jasně, ale dobrý, tak jo,
tak asi to s Pavlou otočte,
nemám AV podstatě adamovku,
Jo.
teda poštov sólo a Lucia,
měli by to stíhat i přes tohle to teďka.
Říkal,
že realizace bude týden na ty datový sítě,
že to jako ale oni jak na elektro i na
data prostě tvrdí, že to stihneme,
Týden.
že to je v pohodě, jo?
Jo a bude to jiná parta než má Michal
bezdivek ne.
Hele nevím,
řešila jsem to s panem želískou. Nevím,
jestli je to ten stejnej pán,
co řešil s diby nebo nebo je to někdo
jinej.
Ne no je to on.
Dobře tak aby to, aby dobře,
tak jo OKOK no tak aby neplánovala,
to až skončí, tak půjdu za váma.
Tak jenom tady připomínám,
jestli to bude takhle.
Kapacitně no.
Já ještě čekám na teda čekáme na to,
že to budeme otáčet.
Jo a to je proti nabídka proti minikomu
jo.
Ano.
A krve to nám tam.
To bylo heslo.
Tam to měl nějak.
Tam bylo nějakých 350.
Cirka tak 2 asi 365 ale cirka jo prosím
tě lucko minulý týden,
když jsme se tady bavili o tom,
že s Lukášem nemáte informace od it,
v pátek se to vyřešilo. Nebo ještě čekáte?
Jako co se týče toho zadání,
tak s tím nám jako nikdo nepomohl,
ale vyřešili jsme to,
že bude potřeba přidat switch do
rozvaděče 1. Myslím, že to je o ve 3.
Patře Lukáš tomsa 1 switch k dispozici má,
takže nemusíme, nemusíme ho kupovat.
AZ it jsme se domluvili potom jak bude
probíhat po tomto následný oživení
zapojení a kolik času na to potřebuju,
tak říkali, že od té doby,
co tam budou fyzicky ty kabely přivedený,
tak na to.
Potřebuji nějaký týden cca týden.
Takže ta spolupráce tady s nebo s
Michalem Luckou letím jako nějak máte?
Máte vykomunikovaný? Jo,
takhle jako ale na prasáka.
Jo.
Co se týče toho hardwaru ne,
ale co se týče toho softwaru jako
takovýho, potom to oživení tak ano.
Jo jo.
Dobře,
takže to je to je ten co bereme takto
zprávu,
že tam jste nějak dovolili a funguje vám
ta spolupráce s nima jo elektro teda
říkáme bude do třicátýho 6 to stíh CPH.
Do třicátýho 6.
Minimálně chceme mít přívody pro ty
nabíječky. Abysme neblokovali element.
A data.
Za řadu.
To je vlastně až společnost.
Těma portama je sociální zašita,
budeme rádi za to.
Nejzažší to nejzažší to není.
Je to termín,
kterej komunikujeme s cetanou,
nejzazší není,
je tam nějakejch tejden ještě buffer,
ale tenhleten tyhlety termíny
komunikujeme s těma s tou s tou cepenou.
Dobře,
ale ten ten tejden je pro projekťáky ne,
který potřebujeme.
U těch dat ano.
Jo.
Tím, že jako element říkal,
že až na konci července stačí,
když tam budou všude připravený ty datový
sítě,
že to jakoby nepotřebuje hned na začátku
července.
Office koho desátýho 7 my víme,
že tam ještě nějaký patříček točí,
Ano.
to bude.
Počkej něco vykupovat.
Dobroš tak.
Pojedeme teda dál,
takže k výtlaku a to stylu,
to je teda všechno to jasně schválení.
To asi bude rychlý ta navýšení příjmu.
Kapacity příjmů je to teda etterys jo.
V riskuje to kvůli tomu it.
To jsem říkala minule, co se ale povedlo,
tak máme schválenej nákup hardwaru pro ty
4 nové BPO stanice,
který budeme přidávat celkem IP 10
hardware jako takový máme stažený interně
jenom čekáme na dodání 4 počítačů,
od it máme plánováno,
že by to mělo být do konce týdne.
Lukáš tomsa natahuje síťový kabely podle
layoutu na nové místa podle podle těch
síťových kabelů potom natáhne cepena
elektro.
A poté může přesunout proběhnout ten
samotný přesun,
ten přesun se mít hotový jako ty další
věci do konce měsíce.
Co se týče toho toho rozdělení portů,
tak jsme se dozvěděli, že po tom,
co se ten port rozdělí,
tak nebude možné to nastavení změnit
zpátky, takže je potřeba si definovat,
kolik na kolika kolik těch trojportů
budeme chtít rozdělit.
Na tom teďka pracoval Vítek,
dneska jsi to měl otáčet s provozem tam
zatím nemám, nemám to finální číslo,
případně jestli víte?
Má nějakou novou informaci?
Ahoj mám jo err pro vycházeli jsme z toho,
že zhruba 1/3 jsou mono palety monopalety
definovaný jako 1 až 3,
maximálně SK up paleta a shodli jsme se
na čísle 6.
Takhle předělaných portů je to těch 6
portů před přípravným pracovištěm a to
hnedka z kraje při vchodu.
Takže ty levé porty,
když se koukáme od jihu?
Koukáme od jihu ano.
Prostě těch 6 u sebe tak?
Jo těch 1 6 dobře.
Ano.
Takže to je tak to je tak jako ve zkratce
právě pro potom co dodáme finální počet,
kolik potřebujeme těch portů,
tak na tak tolik budeme potřebovat těch
USB tlačítek a budem moct Pavel lžička
dokončit ten vývoj. Tam nevím,
jestli je schopný to stihnout do konce
června, nebo to bude trvat déle.
Každopádně jsme se jsme se jako s vítkem
shodli,
že pro to abysme udělali ten příjmový
stres test tu úpravu úplně nutně
nepotřebujeme.
Potřebujeme ji potom do té sezóny.
Co nás čeká do té další schůzky,
tak dodání toho kompletního hardwaru pro
peo stanice. Jak jsem říkala,
chybí nám ty počítače.
To rozhodnutí o počtu rozdělených portů
teda si beru,
že jich je 6 schválit hardware pro ty
rozdělený porty,
že tam budeme potřebovat přidat počítač a
udělat pevný pracoviště a po dokončení
infrastruktury přesunout ty DPO stanice.
Co se týče rizika,
tak hlavní rizika je it vývoj a ten
hlavní milník.
Teďka máme stanovený konec měsíce.
Aby jsme měli všechno připravený pro ten
přímo IZ test.
Top.
Důvod vnímám ze všech těch zpráv,
který jsme tady dneska slyšeli,
že největší riziko změnu tejdne,
což bylo elektrodata,
tak máme víceméně zadenáno.
Světa vyvolaná hvězdička je to kunovat.
Plat.
Dobrý. Díky.
Počkej děkujem, děkujeme. Hele,
já se omlouvám, ještě filippa,
máme tady ještě Filip,
ale já s terkou musím běžet na rozložení
zásoby, ale nás čeká to. Nechci vědět,
že normálně.
Já si myslím Filip v já od tebe informace
mám já od tebe informace mám,
my jsme tam domluvený, tak možná jenom,
jestli máš něco pro Vaška, tak.
Tak to prosím vodreportujte,
já potřebuju běžet na jinou schůzku.
Jasný.
Díky díky všem.
Jo díky, díky.
A.
Hele vašku já budu potřebovat taky za
minutu vypadnout.
Ahoj.
Včera jsme procházeli spolu, ty malstony,
máš tam spíš.
Máš tam teda svým způsobem spíš ty něco
ještě jako otázky.
To já nemám nemám, nemám.
Já jsem v pohodě, my nestačej.
Jo jo.
A to je asi po městě jinak jako.
OK, toto jsou zapsaný kdyžtak jo takže.
Jo v pohodě,
to já si vytáhnu bez bodu z nějakýho
workflow dobře.
OK.
Ok.
Dobro až tak asi všechno.
Já nic nemám těm tématům před.
Dobře, tak jo.
Tak jo.
Tak to je. Díky.
Děkuju.
Pokračujeme dále ještě právě jenom shrnu,
když byste potřebovali pomoct s tím it
obecně, tak se mě ozvěte, jo,
tam se nám to oficiálně komunikuje přes
tu.
A.
Pokud byl problém,
tak případně se tomu jako vrátíme.
Budeme chtít nějaké informaci,
když vám to funguje takhle jako jinak,
si chápu urbancem luckování, nebo tak?
Tak pokračujte dál,
ať vás to jako nezdržuje,
to prostě máte jednoduché. Jo,
jenom kdyby byly nějaký tramvaje,
tak tak to určitě rád pomůžu pomůžu s
inkem.
Situace je taková jaká bohužel je.
Bude tam nějaký změny? Tak.
Jsme šikovné třeba poradit.
Tak jo, děkuju.
OK dobrá.
Dopoledne.
Mějte se, ahoj.
Tak jo.
Ahoj.
Mějte se čau.